learners permit thursdays on my youtube
subscribe today hey guys the night pants
nation tour continues i want to give a
huge shout out to indy especially kim
libby and austin who were huge help
there we had another sold out show and
speaking of sold out shows baltimore
baltimore first show already sold out
saturday october 23rd we added another
show tickets for that are going fast get
your tickets now brea california one
night only october 28th arlington
virginia draft house november 12th and
13th get your tickets at ryansickler.com
the honeydew with ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social media uh reminder about the night
pants nation tour we are out there y'all
it's already kicked off this thing's
rolling uh baltimore i'll see you
october 23rd brea october 28th arlington
virginia november 12th and 13th
cleveland ohio december 9th through the
11th and la jolla december 17th through
the 19th there are already other dates
on the books for 2022 go to
ryanstickler.com
everything's there uh make sure you
subscribe to the youtube channel as well
like i say it means nothing to you and
everything to us if you're watching just
hit subscribe that's all you got to do
that helps us out it's free you know
what i mean and if you subscribe to the
email list you'll get a blast of info a
lot you know
more detailed and earlier than everybody
else and the [ __ ] patreon
look i genuinely love my job and i can't
thank you enough for your support
the patreon's called the honeydew with
you all all right and just in the last
handful of episodes okay i've had a guy
who was paralyzed in the woods off of
60-foot cliff fall
quadriplegic and spent the night for 30
hours in the [ __ ] wilderness by
himself okay with a hole in his [ __ ]
head had a girl uh who
ran a bdsm club and she's ripping
[ __ ] out of guys all right had a
dude that [ __ ] solved an 18 year old
cold case when he found a human skull in
the woods that still had the bullet in
it okay that's what i'm talking about
all right it's five bucks a month all
right if you sign up for a year it you
get over a month free and you get the
honeydew a day early ad free all right
and if you or someone you know has that
[ __ ] story that has to be heard
please submit it to honeydewpodcast
gmail.com i promise you i'm telling you
the emails that are sitting in this
inbox that we're going through this
show's not going anywhere all right so
subscribe be part of that community uh
the
honeydewpodcast.com is the website merch
ringtones all that good stuff now
you know we do over here we highlight
the low lights and i always say these
are the stories behind the storytellers
i'm smiling already because i'm so
stoked to have this storyteller on today
we've been trying to make this happen he
wanted to do zoom i was like nah man you
got to come to the night pants nation
studio so ladies and gentlemen first
time here on the honeydew please welcome
gareth reynolds y'all what's up
hey ryan
it's better without zoom you're right
you're right you were right
i was panicking in a pandemic uh it's
good to follow those stories that you
just plugged on the patreon too that's
like
being brought up after like chappelle
and burr and marin being like all right
everybody yeah everybody's walking
with holes in his head for 30 hours i'm
like this is a story about a tough job
uh let me tell you something the
honeydew of the all those the the
y'all have stories unlocked oh yeah i
mean come on yeah you know i mean yeah
for sure it's insane what's going on
with that show
yeah we've talked to people who've died
what yeah and come back
it's insane on stage
well we'll see about this episode okay
come on guys terrible uh before we begin
please plug everything and anything
you'd like uh well i'm on the road uh so
i'm not sure when this will air but you
can go to gareth reynolds.com for all my
road dates uh you can go to
dolloppodcast.com for dollop tour dates
that podcast is out and running again
soon and then oh you are you're doing
live dollops though yeah okay we're just
about to start and then but we're going
through the rest of the year and then uh
you can go to my youtube which is gareth
reynolds tv and you can follow me on
social media at reynoldsgareth because
some welsh guy
took gareth reynolds ha ha ha ha ha ha
yeah big rugby guy i won't give it back
well you don't want it no he'll forward
stuff yeah but he won't give it back
yeah he'll be like i think you mean this
one and i'm like thank you sir that's
nice yeah it's awkward um well before we
dive into what we're going to talk about
here today i want to tell everybody look
you got to go back to the craft feast
and listen to gary's old episodes you've
got something i mean i hate to jump in
gareth yeah my bad cut that out uh yeah
sure
yeah don't worry yeah we'll get that cut
that edit please yeah sure
um
some great craft feast episodes yeah
but i want to talk about we're going to
talk about today like
you said your decision to move to los
angeles and your
what your idea versus your reality
yeah just what i thought you know like i
i mean i think in retrospect like i'm
very glad i had years of struggling at
this business but when i was going
through it it was was it dark
yeah it gets well okay so
so i moved here right and i moved here
my plan i was really wasn't sure but i
was like pretty confident like i was
like this probably won't that what now
because i know you're a writer as well
so when you come here are you looking to
do stand-up or you just [ __ ] it comedy i
just wanted to act i went to school for
theater so i was like i want to act yeah
that ooze is out of you yeah clearly
clear very much
clearly it's the stain on my shirt it's
the confidence oozing
so uh
so when i see you i'm like that that's a
thespian right there oh yeah that's what
everyone thought around me too people
were like this guy's for sure i want to
say you're missing your calling guys
well i tried the calling missed me
honestly i made the shot the caller was
like we're good i was like did i get
blocked by the calling it's a busy
signal i've heard one of these in here
it's the facts noise and the facts
the early internet
you're like oh this is not good
yeah um
so so like yeah so i come out and uh
my writing partner who was just like a
guy i was performing with at the time
and a bunch of people i went to college
with were like let's start our own like
sketch group and we're like that'll be a
good way and so
uh i
i waited i made i raised money for
myself in boston by valeting cars for
like a year what how much did you come
with
i well and with what i in my head i was
like that'll do the year yeah probably
about six grand man i did five yeah
i was like all right so that's the first
year probably good
yeah after that i'll have to figure
something out within that year yeah yeah
and so that money is [ __ ] and then
you get here and you're like these
apartments don't come with fridges yeah
oh everything yeah you're like first
last secured what
a thousand dollars right now i need to
borrow two i'm gonna go back to boston
for a few months
then i'll come back but i'm going back
hold the unit
and um
and so yeah so i so we basically start
this this sketch group and um
in a the only theater they'll have us
and um
it was
after we after our show there was like
an aaa meeting and we would have kegs of
beer at our show and then so right after
our show we'd like clean up like kegs of
beer we'd feel very guilty you know and
um but
we probably did four or five shows
and a friend of mine from college's
girlfriend is there and she's like what
are you doing for work
and at this point i'm basically just
doing
living off of the fat of that money
that's going away right yeah and then
i'm also doing like test market stuff
like where i'll watch like a tv show and
be like this sucks or like this is
really good or like drink a soda and i
got in there and it wasn't great but i
could make how do you even get into
something like that another person who
was a loser like me was just like hey
you're a loser like this is a good job
for losers
yeah i was like great this is a great
loser job this is perfect
so something to
not an act or a lose they're like come
this way and so um
so i'm like great i'm like yeah i don't
even really understand
what
it is but she's like you know
she's like have you ever thought about
dressing up like costume characters for
kids parties and i'm like oh my god i
didn't even know
that was an occupation i guess in
retrospect i've seen uncle buck yeah
okay it's something that happens i have
missed john candy
and he punches that clown in the nose
the clown is amazing too if you really
want to look at this john candy the best
and so um
so i'm like yeah no great and she's like
yeah you know it's a good way and it's
only weekends which is a great feature
because during the week like i want to
be open to these auditions i'm not going
to book in retrospect but at the time
i'm like i need to make it as an actor
soon
and so it leaves my week open then you
can also write with my writing partner
and stuff like that so
so i go and meet with this guy
and um
the costume guy the guy who's you know
company it is
and um what's it are you allowed to say
what it was called or should you not i
mean i would love i you remember yeah
[ __ ] yeah because
i'll say it because this guy is a great
guy i want to say that like the guy
worked for it was
he really was like the best
children's birthday part like performer
you would ever have but his company was
heihei entertainment
still is yeah
and again hire him he does great work
but he would answer the phone hey hey
and so i eventually got to go like okay
you know it'd be an emergency i'd be
like i'm going to be late for the party
hey cut that out shut up no time for the
second yeah listen to me where is long
beach
because i was like
where is long not near the beach
it's a lot of home depots
uh
so
so i meet with him and he's like you
know he's teaching me how to do this
[ __ ] he's basically like yeah he's like
i think you can do it like does he have
a staff or are you like his first hire
no he has like a crew of people who are
basically like you're basically an
independent contractor so i've hired
these people i've hired a couple ladies
for oh yeah
we have feelings ryan
i hired these people
yeah i hired two of them for my
daughter's birthday one time like
different birthdays but one time also
i'll never forget this is so stupid i
guess this girl had just wrapped a party
you know what i mean she's in the
costume walking to her car and my
daughter starts going there's rapunzel
there's a puzzle and i'm like what are
you i'm part i'm parallel park i'm like
what are you talking about there's no re
she's like yeah and i look across the
street i'm like oh [ __ ] jesus
and she's screaming and the girl like
gives us a look and i look at the girl
i'm like can we come over and say hi
she's like of course sure let's just do
that yeah but she's you're trying to
fall
yeah i do because the prince the hair
was so it's a nightmare i'm so stressed
um
so
so yeah so so he's and he's like you
know he's teaching me all the things i
have to do and i'm passing like what
what is make balloon animals okay which
is the big hurdle can you do that yeah
you can still do that you'll never lose
that skill what's your best uh animal
like what are you like i could do the
poodle tail thing but it would like you
can't in a covered world because you got
to suck the tail a little bit you know
steal a little air from that ass you
know one of those it pops a little
so so that one was that was kind of my
best one but kids would be like ah gonna
be like shut up just
an artist i'm like banksy
um
but also like how to do magic tricks
like the coloring book trick like which
was very
it like for me struck this chord because
i remember so vividly seeing the
coloring book trick where there's
pictures it's where there's pictures
and then they cut they get colored
magically
and then eventually the pictures vanish
and the guy the whole time is going
where where the hell are they and you're
like this is a roller coaster sir we
gotta find these but we had them we had
it
we had it figured out the job was done
yeah yeah yeah
yeah
here we are we're back at scra it's
worse than when you got over here
there's no pictures before we started we
shouldn't have even started so um so
yeah so like
so the magic tricks and then just
certain games and stuff like that and
he's you know he's like giving me like
the run through and he's like yo we'll
do your first party together i'll like
accompany you
and i'm like cool so like i have the job
you know and um
like i said pays pretty well
like it's per party but in a weekend you
could do like
four parties five maybe even in a day
and then a day sometimes like rare rare
times but normally like four sunday
three or four so the whole weekend
you're just like like i remember i would
listen to like
you know klsx or something like that and
they would be like playing like bang on
the drum i don't want to wear it on
friday and i'd be like no no it's my
work weekend yeah you know just because
it was going to be so terrible so so he
i'm my first party shrek
but wait how you work two days average
what would you make you say i could make
like
five between i mean best case five to
six hundred a weekend plus people tip
you yeah p that's a job where people
like hey your life is dog [ __ ] here's
twenty dollars thank you i need it yeah
you
know was done yeah they identified
poodles on point yeah poodle's great by
the way it's 20 for the poodle sir love
how you suck the air to that ass
okay but this this money this five to
six hundred does that afford you to have
your whole monday to friday wide open
for these auditions that you're getting
i would pick up a couple more during the
week but yeah totally like i mean i
wasn't like making good money but i
would still do the test market stuff
every now and then so you know
i was living with uh my girlfriend at
the time she worked uh a little bit too
but like it's close it's tight but it's
enough and i and again in my head i'm
like this won't take too long you know
we're biting ourselves stepping stone
it's we're weeks away from the enemies
or something yeah
dumb little head so um
so my first party is shrek
and are you shrek i'm shrek okay
and he like i said he's gonna like come
along with me but are you in a costume
or is your face painted green you wish
it was that one it's not that one but
keep in mind this head isn't that you're
not like hey shrek you're like did he
get hit with a bat he's like someone
hurt
yeah
[Laughter]
so
so it's for like a baby the party which
is not regular like normally a baby
doesn't even know what it likes i had a
few of those and you're always like
looking at the parents like who did
who's this for like this is
you know like the baby is not like yeah
and you're like what the [ __ ] do i do
and so this one was for like a baby
basically
and it's raining outside so we're inside
so right away it's not going we're in
their home in their home like in their
living room where like there's the 40 of
them you know yeah and i have like i'm
seeing like this
so i'm seeing like through two pinholes
and i'm like they're like watch out for
that table i'm like there's that's the
first i heard of this object
and um and he real quickly like takes
the reins from me
and he's sort of like getting it back on
track you know who is he he's the guy i
told the guy who runs the company his
character he's just a dude in a magical
vest because he's like he's not he's
just wrangling he's just watching he's
like i want to be a face in the crowd
but he's like the shrek cannot navigate
the living room it's for a baby this is
a [ __ ] show so he just starts whatever
making [ __ ] up jazz and uh and they love
it and it goes okay
and so then i guess through that
experience he's like you can do this but
he was like this is rare
and um
so
then i'm in and then it's my job it's my
only job and i'm working it like i said
like all weekend my first party was
dumbledore
and my own like on my own and i was done
with it and i was like
tell me about the drive to that your
first one on your own well in my head
i'm like this is a great job
i'm like i'm can be i can i can just be
like a [ __ ] no problem on the spot
and are you always hidden
no not always no no there was there
would like be nightmare it would i would
prefer to be in a head
but i sometimes i'd be like a prince and
i'd just be like oh this is like feels
real vulnerable you know it was like
because it would just be me and or like
the worst one was when i was harry
potter
because i'm me and harry potter's like
an 11 year old and it was for kids like
who were 11 and they right away were
like why is he so big and i was like
it's a spell it's fine you know like
stuff where i would just be like i did
it to myself i went humongous glorious
yeah like so i would be like you're
throwing to the wolves
so many times in those but that guy's
got patchy facial hair yeah and like the
lightning bolt that i'm putting on my
head i'm like whoop so i'll [ __ ] that up
like it's like a
man yeah it looks more like a zorro yeah
right like oh no
looks mancini it's not coming off i
gotta go in with so many stressors in
life it's difficult to maintain
effective nutritional habits and give
our bodies the nutrients it needs to
thrive ag-1 by athletic greens the
category-leading superfood product
brings comprehensive and convenient
daily nutrition to everybody to help
each of us be at our best they simplify
the path to better nutrition by giving
you the one thing with all the best
things i take one tasty scoop of ag-1
before i work out every day and it
contains 75 vitamins minerals and whole
food sourced ingredients including a
multivitamin multimineral probiotic
green superfood blend and more in one
convenient daily serving the special
blend of high quality bioavailable
ingredients in a scoop of ag-1 work
together to fill the nutritional gaps in
your diet they support your energy and
focus they aid with gut health and
digestion and support a healthy immune
system effectively replacing multiple
products or pills with one healthy
delicious drink
to make it easy athletic greens is going
to give you an immune supporting free
one year supply of vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase if you visit
athleticgreens.com
honeydew today again simply visit
athleticgreens.com honeydew to take
control of your health and give ag-1 a
try what would you do if you didn't have
high interest loans or credit card debt
with upstart you can pay off your
existing debt quickly and easily and
start living your life upstart is the
fast and easy way to pay off your debt
with a personal loan all online whether
it's paying off credit cards
consolidating high interest debt or
funding personal expenses over a million
people have used upstart to get one
fixed monthly payment with a clear
payoff date rather than looking at
credit score alone upstart considers
other factors like your income your
current employment and credit history to
find you a smarter rate for your loan
you can even receive funds as fast as
one business day after accepting your
loan find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com honeydew that's upstart.com
honeydew don't forget to use my url to
let them know i sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application
upstart.com honeydew now let's get back
to the duke but you're on your way to
your first gig dumbledore and uh and it
goes well you know like as well as this
stuff goes and so i'm like okay i can do
this and
i
i do it for ages i'm doing it every
weekend i kind of
i don't mean this to sound like a brag
and i don't think it will but i was like
his best
guy
out of how many out of like
seven eight fluctuating you know but
there were certainly some
like there were certainly some
situations where i was like this person
should not oh so you would work with
other people so yeah sometimes sometimes
you show up and be like shaggy what are
you doing
man i'm [ __ ] drunk you'd be like
buddy they can hear you would you get
your [ __ ] together
um i'm not even saying his people but
you would def like there was definitely
a spectrum and um
and so well also the way you do it is
you meet a guy in a parking lot you pick
up your costumes that's how you find out
what your weekend is everything fine
sounds shady as [ __ ] i met a man in a
parking lot on fridays for costumes
what's your is that really yeah
that's when you're finding out your off
that's when you don't even know well one
time
yeah one time i i had i was batman at uh
my agents at the time and i was like no
i can't it was too late so i heard no
yeah so on the weekend i went to my
agency
and i'm just going like what do you mean
at the actual office at the
office yes they were like not someone at
the agency's home no someone at the
agency ordered at the agency for a child
it was believe me i was like what the
this is a i didn't expect this to ever
happen that's a twilight yeah i was like
this is targeted at me and you had to go
be batman yeah did they recognize no no
way even worse
that was worse actually
none of that
no people just got like i know i have a
bunch of clients to do a book [ __ ] i'm
like hey give them a shot
when i was a boy i went through some
trauma and it worked out pretty well
give him a shot him or her sorry i'm not
just
um
so that's how you so that's how you get
the costumes and stuff so then i'm going
on i'm going you know i'm i'm going
full-on
going full-on
uh in this world
you know story you're enjoying it i
forgot
okay so you've told yourself at least
it's a good gig for a minute and then it
starts to become a gig where i'm like
okay this is like how long in
i would say probably about a year or so
okay i'm doing it for years
years how many years
well the first stretch probably about
three and a half oh there's a return to
the gig
there's about three and a half years
that's that's a that's a chunk maybe
three i don't know that's a minute yeah
yeah for sure so hundreds of parties
yeah and um how many peop did you ever
run into any other one on you knew and
all the time yeah one time this one
sucked one this is another [ __ ] one one
time i was at uh i was mr incredible at
a house in beverly hills and the head of
my uh manager's company was there again
didn't
mark me he didn't he wasn't like gareth
and this is just one of these
yeah yeah um but this director who i'd
worked with was like yeah and then our
recovery into a conversation about work
it's you know he was like yeah so what
you've been up to and i'm like i'm uh
just a general uh loser how have you
been you know i was like good to see you
you're in that [ __ ] outfit yeah
i'm good i'm really good
what do you mean
really good things the business is going
great like the work is flowing
honestly i haven't oh i do this i do i'm
sorry i just realized i'm just mr
incredible
yeah so so there were a few of those
so when you stopped
because it got to be too much well no
because
so the whole time you know i'm cracking
away with money you finally got that gig
well my right
partner and i were like okay we're
um
we ended up
getting we so we started doing like
freelance marketing by day and they
would basically just be like how many
days did you work this week and we would
be like four and they'd be like
okay we'll give you you know two
thousand dollars to split so we were
like we had this loophole job going on
and for one of the things we did we made
this uh like infomercial idea and axe
body spray was like hey we actually want
to use you two for an ax campaign
and so just real roundabout and random
but i end up getting a year-long deal
sorry it's an axe campaign party we'd
like to hire you to come and no
no no
right this way all your agents are here
they won't recognize yeah don't worry
he'll be fine it's a fully lit club
nobody will even know it's you
could wear a sign with your name on it
nobody give a [ __ ] you're gonna be
lebron james from space jam okay i don't
know how you're gonna pull it off but
good luck
there's no costume
on friday
that sort of [ __ ] would happen really
well just crazy [ __ ] where they just be
like
um you know
you just they'd be like do a lot of
karate and you'd be like what no look
you don't get to tell me what my skills
are you know
it's not like the matrix or you can just
put like a chip in my brain so they
would just [ __ ] or or parents
expectations you know would just be like
no you you're due like a perfect you
know you just you'd have to reset
expectation all the time
um you ever have any dust-ups at the
parties any like people get upset
any drunks any crazy [ __ ] go down you
see families fighting or anything you're
in the middle of batman it would be
separate if there would be well there
would always be people who have like if
you were like dressed like spongebob
would just whack your nose oh yeah the
whole time and you'd just be like on the
inside like i'm going to find out his
car like i will ruin i will find revenge
swears under the head just like
um and then yeah you'd see you'd see
beef
that would happen a lot you would see
i mean i it's also weird because you
could watch people watch you in a way
that
uh was almost voyeuristic so you could
watch people be like i wonder what his
deal is like and you'd just be like
trying it was almost like reading your
comments online it was just it was like
it was the old version of reading your
comments
yeah like in real time
hearing and feeling criticism from all
angles hearing it yeah what's some [ __ ]
you remember hearing uh dude i remember
people being like like literally
pointing out you're a loser
um saying yeah laughing at you what does
it take to do something like i bet he's
an actor you know stuff where you're
like
buddies
dude you're just like dressed up like
the riddler like i've got a riddle my
life
i'll be in the car
please tell me
now i want bannon to kill me
oh here's why i'm also a batman yeah
yeah which i have the costume for in my
car this is a great batman story i one
time um
they wanted me to make an entrance over
the roof
get the [ __ ] who's asking people to do
something i don't know
they're over there you get up on the
route and i'm like uh yeah because you
want that tip you know you want it's
just it's just like any gig economy you
know the tip's not guaranteed you still
are trying to make the situation so what
are you doing are you parkouring up
there
look at them they get a ladder they get
a ladder they get a a
tall tape and everything on and you're
going up on the roof dropping hula hoops
i'm like buddy i'm like someone put the
cape over me like a bride's veil or some
[ __ ] you know so uh
so
so i just would like to see batman like
carefully going up a ladder instead of
batman
jesus
my honda keys i mean the mobile keys my
honda keys
i use a honda key to
disguise the batkey
okay so
so it's like how high is this [ __ ]
room
you got to get out of it how you'd get
out of like a low pool
like where you got to do the jump push
[ __ ] you know where you got to give
yourself a hip hope
and and the step ladder is a step ladder
so it goes up as high as so whatever so
i get up there i go on the other side
i'm like hey jeremy it's your birthday i
guess he's [ __ ] here go over here
we're gonna hang out and then i go back
to the other side and then like knowing
this now way more than i did then it's
very
getting back onto the ladder so much
more precarious and difficult
so the kids are watching that part where
i'm like is it closed am i like pushing
myself back up where my feet did
did i touch it
mom you know you're really close it
doesn't feel like i'm closed make sure
my feet are hit again
well like 20 minutes into the party
yeah these kids are just like
is that really him
i feel like it's not him
oh so
it's going on
so it's going on for years man
just [ __ ] like that some weekend's great
sometimes like i remember being a kid
like a big kid like getting like kind of
like pushy with me as santa i was really
i was a grinch once and i was like i
think this is a cult like as i was
walking around i was like oh they're
like a full-on cult it was in the middle
of nowhere
um
just tons and tons oh pamela anderson
and tommy lee's kid one time broke my
staff my
um my like wizard staff like you did
their party i was doing paul mitchell's
party on the fourth of july paul
mitchell yeah the hair guy yeah but the
guy you picture is paul mitchell it's
this dumb story but he's not really paul
mitchell he just bought it and now
everyone thinks he is but yeah he has a
big party on the fourth all these people
are there i end up doing
schwarzenegger's party because of that
party so there'll be things like that
too why were you at that party i was
just a games coordinator so i was just a
referee for four hours and that got you
the gig at uh arnold's party oh no sorry
that at that one i was um
it was called the dark magician
and it's it's the weird it was like a
four foot long extension head
a staff okay it was the worst because
you couldn't you'd like try to go under
doorways and they'd be like the
chandelier you'd be like sorry i really
where's that can we where's outside um
but yes you had a staff so their kid
just broke it and then
through that yeah did schwarzenegger i
was just the games coordinator so there
was stuff like that but it was still
like i mean really i was like every
weekend i was going man it's getting
harder and harder so so we get this job
doing this axe gig and basically what
we're doing for
this website is we're going across the
country just like talking to women
um
trying out like different techniques on
how to it's really dumb obviously but
trying different techniques on how to
pick up women and the whole thing is
kind of like scripted and so we're
trying to make it funny and they're
trying to make it brandy
and so it's not very good and then their
website is terrible but uh but it gives
me this time when i when i walked away
you know i give my two weeks notice or
you know whatever my like 12-party
notice
and i'm like yeah so i uh so i'm good
and i go off for a full year do that
then we also did this thing where we
went to uh this evan and i separately
for like comedy central's website at the
time went to this place called the
testicle festival and we shot this video
there where it's like rocky mountain
oysters it's just a total [ __ ] show
and so
we we had that we were kind of cutting
that out
yeah are they good no they're not i mean
you can stomach a couple like i don't
even eat meat anymore so i don't know if
i could take down
how big is the bar then is they make you
take the whole [ __ ] ball right down
well it's like mashed so it's almost
like a mallet it's been taken and then
it's breaded but then it's got cocktail
sauce so it's almost like
cocktails yeah that's what you're both
yeah yeah yeah yeah nothing's better
yeah and so the cocktail sauce and the
breading helps but yeah i mean at some
point you're going like this it's like
[ __ ] it's a nut but yeah cutting it
and taking bites
is it like a fried oyster where you're
just popping it's bigger than an oyster
yeah i feel like it's a ball it's a big
flat it's pan it's a pancake
testicle
so you're all right we're ripping down
these pancake testicles and we shot this
video and
we were at the place where we were doing
the ax thing from
and ben silverman who at the time had
like brought the nba nbc the office to
nbc and all the stuff and he ended up
running nbc and is a big [ __ ] and still
is he he's there
and we're just talking about this thing
and we mentioned that we did this test
we put on the testicle festival video he
[ __ ] loves it so he wants to take out
a show based on the ax thing
so we go and we pitch this show this is
over like two and a half three years
we go and pitch this show
we end up writing a script for comedy
central we end up selling them they pick
it up to pilot this the first thing
we've ever written it's terribly written
you know like we don't know what we're
doing but we get a huge budget for a
pilot
we make this pilot
we're
not super happy with the results but we
still think we have a shot and so we're
going to be waiting for like three and a
half months to find out because we're
early in um the session they're doing
that year and uh
as that's happening and in process i
make great money on the axe thing but i
was told over and over again like
dude you're gonna be this is gonna
launch you so i'm going this is my last
job real after this it's all easy money
you know so that money at this point is
starting to go
and i'm starting to go okay well i i
think like
[ __ ] like the career like financially i
really need this thing to get picked up
because you know i'm like i haven't made
great money lately and this is it and so
we're waiting wait wait wait wait are
you three weekends away from spongebob
man
that's like my shawshank so
so
so
we're waiting
i'm like i need to get a job again a
real job so my brother has a
construction company in la
in the interim he's like started and i
used to paint houses and so you know
he's like yeah you can work
so i start working for him by week
and you know that labor is i mean it's
the labor i was doing was like a lot of
demolition and a lot of tiling and [ __ ]
like that so you know hard work so i'm
like getting drained and i'm not making
a ton of money off it but i'm like
that's enough combined with what i have
but i need this thing to get picked up
so
because in my head i'm like
i'm not [ __ ] going back to kids
birthday parties like i was very
the separation i felt from that job was
so final
that i was like i will not do that you
know
so
it's going on and um
it's like the week we're gonna find out
it's the day we're gonna find out and
i'm tiling this wall
and um and i'm like on edge and not
sleeping great because i am like at this
point stressed about it and
the grout that i'd mixed was not good so
i'm kind of watching like i'm like just
in the middle of going like man i've
really [ __ ] up this task i was asked
to do like i gotta redo the grout get
the grout off like redo this tiling job
basically and as i'm watching it fall
apart my manager calls i'm like okay i
go outside and i'm like what's the word
and he's like we gotta wait for evan so
i'm like that seems weird and then yeah
he's like no it's getting passed on
and so i'm like okay so i'm like taking
it on the chin
i go back
to the tiling
and um
and i'm just like i gotta go to the guy
i was working with i was like i can't
really process it what my life is right
now because i kind of had built a nice
like you know i had my own apartment
like felt like things were kind of
decent
and um
and just dawns on me like real quick
like gotta go back to it
and um
so i call my boss
hey and uh i'm like hey you know i need
to come back he's like oh great he's
happy to have me
uh i'm really going through like [ __ ]
[ __ ] like feeling you know depressed on
many levels also
you know there's like career depressed
then there's like financial depressed
like i'm like i'm [ __ ] i like i'm not
sure what i'm gonna do like how how i'm
gonna get ahead of this i hadn't planned
really well you know so um
so i go back and i do the parking lot
meet with the guy
and he's like
you're back huh you know and i'm like
yeah and he's like i know you'd be back
you little [ __ ]
[Music]
he goes you know
people always come back he goes there's
this guy he was a bassist his band went
off i told him i said you'll be back you
know they always come back and i'm like
cool man really [ __ ] good to catch up
i need more bubbles i need balloons too
and um
and then i go back into it
and my first one is an old-timey batman
gray suit batman
and i'm like sitting in my car
adam west batman like the most like the
one that you were like i remembered i
was like you don't want this one because
the kid's like who is this you're like
the roots of batman children let's have
a historical
and uh and i'm just sitting in my car
and i just start you know like crying
and just kind of
realizing like just as batman dressed as
batman well
either either at minimum neck down
dressed up might not have committed to
this part yet though i probably should
have to cover up the right man sitting
in a honda crying
30 feet away where a pool party is that
i'm about to go to where kids like it's
soon enough and that'll be cake and it's
like nah [ __ ]
cake did your honda have original rooms
oh yeah that's what i'm talking about
yeah don't you worry i never i never got
that crazy
you never had the money anyway no no no
no but even i mean i don't think that i
want to put it in the room i don't think
it's necessarily money based on the rims
i think that's like i probably splurged
in a different way people it's still a
honda yeah it's a hobby you know it's
like
why not upgrade the anyway so i'm crying
crying
and um
go and do it
and then do it oh you're crying before
you go and do it oh yeah
oh yeah they're gonna say after you it's
both to be fair
it's not just one you know you can cry a
bunch of today
yeah
you stay hydrated you can do four to
seven cries no issues
so yeah i had an am and a pm cry and uh
and so i'm like you know in my car like
fathoming my life
and um oh god and then that whole
weekend i do a bunch of them and then
that sunday night
um
i get this email from my boss and he's
basically just like uh
you know
he saw me at one of the parties because
he was doing magic tricks so he's like
hey you know i saw you i just a couple
notes and i was like uh
notes
and then uh notes notes
and then i was back in it for another
probably two years
where i didn't i wouldn't even tell
people like because
what we had done
was felt like a thing it was very hard
for me to own my reality when i kind of
had sunk back down and it really was
about a year of um
financial impossibility where i was
borrowing money from friends
you know when i made
some money here or there for a gig would
pay people back
but i mean i was working construction
five four five days a week depending on
like if i had another gig going or
something every weekend was doing that
was doing commercials thank god was like
in that world and would get would make
scratch through that but really for a
year was just like
living so
like i mean i think obviously people
have it way worse like i could afford to
eat but i was eating like microwavable
pizzas not by choice like i was not
going out i was you know kind of like a
freeloader um
and
it was the stretch of time that like
just
really would and it was just constant
misery and
worry and and also like people who
believed in me felt i could stop
believing in me
including myself
and um yeah just really like
in a way so great in retrospect because
it made me learn a really valuable
lesson
but at the time i mean what lesson
that you know
you can't you just can see what's right
in front of you you should not think too
far ahead especially in this business
confidently as hard as that is
it's something that sticks with me all
the time as far as
don't believe your own hype
don't be too down on yourself but also
you know my when you get paid in this
business hold on to your [ __ ] money
and don't be the guy who's like i'm
going to pick up every tab because
everything's fine like you there's so
many people that you see
you know on the other side of a a spike
and look i mean it's going to happen to
us at some point
yeah so it's it's going to come so
you know you want to be a little more
prepared and and to not live beyond your
means and also i think especially in la
so real quick let me ask you because i
learned that same lesson i learned it
differently i learned it from like when
my father died no will
no anything no nothing you know he was
42 so he wasn't even expecting it but
also nothing
so what i learned when i made a little
money
instead of holding on to it in the sense
that because
it's what you say you're scared to spend
money because you don't know what the
[ __ ] next check is gonna be yeah
you're scared to go do anything and
enjoy your life because god forbid i
just went to a vacation and now i don't
have money for food or rent or whatever
but
i put money away and i went and got
life insurance which my father didn't
have for my daughter i went and got a
living will and trust which my father
never had so that way it doesn't go into
court and every parasite picks off of it
and by the time it gets to your [ __ ]
kids it's not even worth what it's
supposed to so i put money into that and
i went and did
all these things to make sure that if
there's an untimely demise of me before
whatever the [ __ ] it i don't know 60
something that my daughter at least is
got a great head start and doesn't have
to dig out of the [ __ ] hole yeah that
i had to dig out of
yeah i mean uh
it really like
i've tried to like
not just have my money in a bank but by
the same token i mean i feel like like
i'm my mother is very similar to the way
like where i'm just like i don't spend
money on [ __ ] every time i do my taxes
my guys like that's like you just have
shots i'm like yeah i did a bunch of
shots this year like i never really but
i live very meekly for the most part
with like what i spend money on and
things like that because
i don't i mean i
you learn that lesson that way
that hard you go yeah i'm not gonna [ __ ]
future me
exactly you know and you do have to
think like that and it's hard because in
this you know in our job it's like such
a day-to-day
grind that it's
it's hard to live like just day to day
but you kind of have to i mean you kind
of like just they're searching for food
every day just like everyone else you
know but um
yeah it really like the fact that i got
through that made me go
okay i can
hang around at least for a little longer
but it really i was dependent on friends
and
you know the people around you really
like
stepped up i talk about therapy on the
show a lot and i think therapy is great
for all of us um and i know a lot of
people are scared a lot of dudes don't
think that's macho think you're soft i'm
telling you it's not man
meeting with the therapist to work on
your mental health it's just as helpful
as hiring a personal trainer to work on
your physical health and the positive
impact can be just as life-changing
alright so talkspace makes it possible
to speak with a licensed therapist right
from your phone your tablet or your
computer you know i think it's
so good to dive into your past and
really figure out what's going on with
you why all that stuff and that's what
this show's all about we're highlighting
the lowlights and digging up all that
trauma whether you struggle with anxiety
depression self-doubt or anything else
talk space gives you access to the help
you need to move forward facing those
obstacles isn't easy and you don't win a
prize for doing it alone join talk space
today and start moving forward with a
single message just visit talkspace.com
and get a hundred dollars off your first
month when you use promo code honeydue
signup that's 100 off at talkspace.com
promo code honeydew take a moment to
answer this question how are you feeling
today if the answer is anything less
than great it's time to learn more and
demand better for your body take control
of your health and well-being with an
at-home lab test from everly well everly
well offers affordable at-home lab tests
to give you trusted physician-reviewed
results choose from tests including food
sensitivity metabolism sleep and stress
thyroid and so much more here's how it
works everly well ships your test
straight to your door with everything
needed for a simple sample collection
you're going to return the test to a
clia certified lab with a prepaid
shipping label then your physician
reviewed results and insights are sent
to your device in just days over 1
million people have trusted everly well
with their at-home lab testing including
me i got the food sensitivity on the way
i actually was going to look for one
because ever since cove my stomach's
been a wreck eating all kinds of
different stuff's affected me and now i
want to know so i'm getting the food
sensitivity test and i will be telling
you exactly how it goes and for
listeners of my show everly wells
offering a special discount of 20 off
and at home lab test at everlywell.com
honeydew that's everlywell.com honeydew
for 20 off your at home lab test
everlywell.com
honeydew now let's get back to the duke
so what happened at the end of that two
years like what were you able to what
happened we were able to finally say all
right i'm out of this [ __ ] well we two
things one that i told that [ __ ] you
were out and i was like yeah i'll be
back
see on the other side
i'll come back
well in my head
it's always there
i'm always like i don't know if i'm
fully done
you know really like i am like there
could be a situation where i'm like [ __ ]
you know i need money and go back and
he'll be there yeah exactly he'll be
like 80 be like i told you
smoking yeah i only do santas now i
thought you'd be back
and uh
i do i think that all the time like
santas and wizards yeah oh dude wizard
is always a good time
um
but yeah i mean i i definitely think
like i don't know it's like
you know you have maybe
two existences in a way you have the one
where you kind of learn how to be a
human and then in this industry like you
know maybe different than others but
there's probably parallels you learn how
to be like a person in this business and
how to actually survive and
how to just block [ __ ] out and focus on
because someone always says it better
someone always has it worse it's really
easy to like
feel like you're gonna compensate in
that by
you know spending money and [ __ ] like
that but not when it's at the cost of
going back to being batman and the
riddler yeah no
so what was your
upbringing like like what was your
family life like
well i was raised by english people in
wisconsin so and then and
my parents were immigrants
they moved to
ohio and then wisconsin my little
brother my little brother my older
brother is 12 years older than me okay
so they had him
and then they brought to you
yep
well at the start and then
my parents um
they basically
yeah we're not supposed to be like i
even talked to my parents about this now
and they both agree like yeah they were
not supposed to be married
why'd they get married i think literally
because they didn't know that you
weren't supposed to
like when i asked my dad it wasn't an
option not too yeah i was like i met
someone so yeah probably gotta start
having a family quickly you know and
that was just what they did and so they
just linked up like real
early like my mother was 19
and um
and then yeah they just got to it but
they
but they
did this thing where like they didn't
want to
um
tell me they were gonna get a divorce so
when i was seven they sat me down and
they're like we're getting a separation
and like i knew what divorce was like
even in you know like in a kind of like
whatever child form a nascent form of it
but
that i didn't understand and they're
like so he's gonna be leaving but he's
gonna be coming back a bunch and you
know we're not necessarily done and all
that stuff so i was like okay
and um
that went on for
years
where sometimes my father was living
there sometimes he wasn't sometimes they
were like together sometimes they
weren't sometimes they would be arguing
all the time
but and he would be moving stuff out
then he'd be moving stuff in and went on
for seven years where i wasn't able ever
to really
and i didn't even feel like i could ask
you know it was so just watching this
yeah just oh you're back yeah just this
come back yeah i told you
how did he get it here
they all come back
yeah
i knew i knew you
yeah so
so yeah so they like did that forever
so wait real quick your brother how much
older 12 12 years so you're being sat
down at seven so at 19 he knows what the
[ __ ] going on you don't talk to him or
is he out of the house already he's out
of the house i mean honestly no like he
definitely was trying to explain it to
some extent but
you know nobody could really define what
that is what it was yeah right so he was
even a little like weirded out but yeah
he was gone a lot he was great to me
like he would sneak me captain crunch
boxes and stuff like that you know he
was the man but he also like you know
it's kind of their job to be like here's
what our relationship is or something
and um
so after seven years of that
and a story that i really only got all
the pieces of in the last like you know
few years really when i really talk to
my parents but
you know essentially my
they one would want to break up one
would want to get back together when
they were in a phase where it looked
like they were kind of together to me
my father was dating a woman he worked
with and then we found out like she was
pregnant and then my dad was like you
know gonna have a baby with her then
they got married and then so i kind of
shut down and like left you know my
father alone for didn't talk to my
father for three or four years oh and he
didn't try to reach out or anything
either he did he really wanted to have a
relationship but i just was like so
furious
i mean i was watching my mother kind of
be broken and it that was breaking me
as well as i was broken from my own pain
you know and um
and that really was it i just was like
i'm [ __ ] done it wasn't until i was
gonna go to college
that
one of the deal like my parents had a
super
uh bad divorce i so bad that i had to
get my own lawyer and like yeah at like
14 they were like you need a lawyer and
i wanted my lawyer wait what do you
think are you joking right now you [ __ ]
with me where to go no no no why did you
have to have your separate lawyer
because and why if you're 14 do you have
to go find that [ __ ] i don't
know they was i don't even know who was
like someone was just like this is your
attorney and i mean right away i met him
and i was like what the [ __ ] and all
three of you have to have a different
attorney yeah we all
but you're not even in this
no but it was like because i didn't want
to see my father there was all this like
pulling going on
to the point where i needed to have a
lawyer to kind of communicate to my
father's camp what i was thinking
but yeah i mean i mean i got i would
have relished the opportunity to be in
the courtroom and just be like can we
talk foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and then i have to go to therapy but
also the lawyer dude like i knew from
hockey like i i played with his kid oh
okay so i was like this is kind of weird
like and he was like watch i know you
from hockey but also i'm willing to be
your attorney and i was like i'd rather
keep it as a hockey relationship
um
but so so yes and then talk to my father
for years then through therapy basically
like we came to terms to just to talk
you know when i was about 18. all right
let's talk about that well how did that
come about
so
it essentially was um
i
couldn't qualify for financial aid at
the school i wanted to go to
because um my father at the time was
making decent money
and but i had no relationship with him
so we were trying to basically say like
there you know there's an arrangement
but i'm not part of that school wouldn't
have it so i basically had to be like
can you help me partially with college
and um
and we kind of like met like in this
arrangement where i was like i will
try to reopen myself well my my
therapist who was awesome was basically
like you know
i think your father is willing to do
that but he definitely wants to feel
like you're a part of his life again and
deep down i mean that is something i
want i mean i love my dad you know i was
just furious and acted out in ways that
were
bonkers like our school had a school
store and it was tied to his account
so i would go there
like a dude like a guy who just sold a
franchise like the guy you're talking
about in hollywood that's pissing all
the money away i wanna buy everyone's
shots i'm gonna buy everyone a
calculator like we you're all getting
nutty buddies today but what's around
the ti-85 so let's do some school shall
we yeah give me a two-hole punch yeah
and some threes barbara some threes in
the back cassidy said you guys have
something just got in
if you go x if you go behind the binders
near the traffic keepers exactly let me
let me get back there and show you what
i'm talking about so i'm like [ __ ]
just making it rain in the school store
it got cut off
they had to cut you i went there legit
for like a pencil one day they're like
you can't get anything from here again i
was like can i not get a pencil there
like you spent like four thousand
dollars on yourself we're gonna need you
to like
not come here anymore i was like that's
understandable we had a good run though
hi ladies
um
and then yeah and then that sort of
opened me up to talking to him there
were all these little things in my head
that i was like i'm never gonna tell him
i love him i'm never gonna like really
you know but as time went on it was like
not only did i forgive him you know as
it's very hard to re-engage in that
stuff but i
once i did it was like okay
this there's the person that i love here
and um and now we do have a [ __ ]
great relationship you know but he did
have three other kids or three others i
was going to say do you have a brother
or sister he has a brother or two
sisters
and so well he has five kids yeah your
mom's still just two of you yeah yeah
she was like i'm good this is uh yeah
yeah five kids a lot of fun kids well
and i used to really crave like a like i
would go to school with people who'd
have like good families and they'd have
like pictures of their families in their
house and like you know them dressed up
as like western characters and [ __ ] and
i would always be like oh i just want
that and so i would try to get that
going in my house you know but people be
like no we're not going to sears you
know but jeff bremmer went to sears and
his family looks great
and then when i went to my dad's house
finally to meet the kids they got all
these things all over like where they're
like western
just like sneaking one of myself in
there put one in the corner right the
right at the bottom like the kid who has
the soccer ball in front of him
coming
so he went he wouldn't have the family
you wanted to be a part of yeah
and it's one of those things too it's
like it's not i don't
i'm not i'm not saying anything out loud
it's just you know it's like you're
in your brain you're like a man's mind
is melting right now
[Laughter]
oh
[ __ ]
but he was stoked to have you back i'm
sure oh yeah yeah
oh my god i mean i may i uh
yeah you know i mean it's your dad it's
hard it's hard it's i i think
i never judge anyone for making any of
those decisions but my my situation was
definitely
you know it was a it was it was just i
was so hurt you know and i think when
you're
living under the literal roof of the
woman he hurt who is your mom and you're
watching her fall apart it just well
dude we started like
my mother and i like formed i mean my
mother and i get along on a level that's
just bananas um actually we had a web
thing we did called
if people want to watch that on my
youtube where i talk to her but she we
we like
we became like sisters
you know i mean i was like girl you
don't even need to tell me
like and we started like i figured out
she smoked cigarettes i smoked
cigarettes we were like should we just
open this up to smoking in the house and
then that's just like
16 you know i'm like mom can you believe
it solve the puzzle janet get it
together
you know like we formed this like
amazing bond throughout it so it but it
was yeah it was like
you know you when you you you hurt but
when you see someone you love hurt on
the same situation you're like
so um but yeah now i have a great
relationship with both of them and they
have not spoken once no i remember the
last time how's it possible they didn't
see each other at your graduation or no
i shut my dad out of most of that [ __ ]
okay because you were 14 and he okay
yeah she didn't come or anything huh i
think maybe we had a i think because he
showed up just in the back away from her
actor
he came to one of my plays oh he did and
he was allowed to like watch from a
distance
but then he like got me flowers or
something and i was like [ __ ] him who
wants flowers you know
but um
but no he was he i kept him to the
sideline man i was really like
you know i put my mother first in all
those situations because i was like he's
moved on he's got a new situation you
know my mother and i they have two
children together and not once if they
had to communicate in all how many years
it's over 20. i mean wow yeah it's like
i mean it's almost over it's almost 30.
you know it's getting close at least
yeah but it's yeah it's like over time
are you close to your other siblings
i've gotten to be yeah yeah um
you know it took a while
and uh and again like i said i set up
all these rules of things i was gonna do
to make my father uh experience my
trauma you know turn it back and one of
them was like never meet his kids and
then eventually acquiesced you know and
then i saw the picture of the western i
was like i'm [ __ ] out of here i knew
i should have done this [ __ ]
you know what this is a bad idea ah i
think the cab still out front
that's helpful is that a big trampoline
prominently
you told me they were dangerous well
they they didn't have them with nets
back then you could have gotten a
separate
them wouldn't that's like that
but they've been able to build a net
around it i was like yeah technically
i guess i'll let you off of that one how
you're but you have a good relationship
now though yeah yeah yeah yeah but you
said he had some health problems
recently yeah so um
you know he uh
how old is your dad now he's 73 okay and
um he had a
you know i mean i
like
as you alluded to like when your father
passed like it gets weird when you get
older with your parents you know because
you do start going like oh [ __ ] there is
this
you know this natural cycle of life and
and i've been very lucky that both my
parents have been pretty healthy for
most of my life my mother's you know had
a couple like had a couple tumors
removed but it was never anything more
than just like a surgery and she was
okay
um
but
you know the thing that i always kind of
dreaded was the suddenness of that and
then so
i wake up one morning and i've missed
like five calls and it's from my
sister's and my my brother so i'm going
okay something's [ __ ] up i call my
brother you know he's like a dad had a
stroke
and um
he had a stroke like and he drove
himself to the hospital while he was on
the stroke he said it took him two hours
to get 20 minutes okay so he was all
stroked like people like this dude doing
you know like beeping and driving just
like signaling
[Applause]
yeah we're in a burger king crown like
who is this
should he be driving
and um
and so i'm like oh [ __ ] you know uh
as the day unfolds they're like you know
he's i talked to him in the waiting room
and he's just going i i i i i i i this
is a guy who like people like you know
where did you get your sense of humor i
would watch my father and he can't
i can't say [ __ ]
and i'm just like oh [ __ ] um
you know and you recognize there's
i mean at that point you're like just
make this person alive you know
they see him
i talk to him the next day he's really
unable to
communicate again
um same stuff but i now i'm facetiming
him i see his eyes
he's trying to say so much [ __ ] my
friend uh who's as a mother as
alzheimer's same sort of thing you see
that
there's so much that wants to come out
and he's overwhelmed my dad loves to
talk i
i i i i and i'm going i'm going i go out
i it's crazy and you want to tell me
everything but you can't and he's going
i i want you to put on that batman cop
yeah
i'm sorry we didn't get western pictures
together
[Laughter]
the only thing you could say is that
they did make them with nets when i was
a kid they did
they did sam's club
so he's got you know he's unable to do
it i'm just going it's okay you know i'm
my two my sisters are nurses so that's
very helpful and
and then
there
he starts having seizures
and while you're talking to him no no
but like my sister's calling me in tears
she's going he just had a seizure and
i'm going okay and they're going they
think it's a regular and all this stuff
and then he has another seizure
then he goes to the icu then he's
intubated
and so then you you are like going like
oh [ __ ] you know like i'm gonna you know
lose this person
and um
and that is what we thought you know for
a
full two days really
where we're sort of going
i don't think this would happen where
we're sort of going uh
you know it's
who knows i mean you are thinking like
i mean in many ways with a stroke you're
going i've had my last conversation with
this person but you are going i will
take the version where i can just look
into someone's eyes and you know
whatever i'll take yeah whatever
whatever it is
so they put him on some seizure stuff
and it kind of like it just
changes the game completely where he
he
they're like it's crazy what's happening
because he's now i face time with him
maybe two days after this when he's
allowed to to do it again and he's i
mean he's basically he's basically
comatose for a couple days and um
i'm talking to him
and he's going
it was so difficult but
i was
able to
um talk to the doctor you know what i'm
going what the [ __ ] all from this
medication yeah you i'm not
i mean even fully sure like it was a
blood clot you know that's what i wanted
to ask you what was the stroke so it was
a blood clot it was
um where
it was from his heart and his heart yeah
and so the blood clot like
i i guess shot it was fragments so it
wasn't like there was one it was like a
klotz coming so this is the coming
attraction of the disaster film that's
in his heart right this is the trail
this is the previous yeah and uh
and so they're able to recognize that
then the seizure medication they give
him in conjunction with other stuff
they'd been giving him just kind of like
frees it up his brain was probably under
seizure the whole time
and they gave him this thing that just
kind of put it back to stable
and then he was able to start
communicating and then you know over a
couple weeks then they they removed the
clot
um
and he yeah has made a recovery that is
crazy i mean to the point where
you know i i can't really tell you know
when i talk wow really it's like that
now it's nuts i mean i was just there i
was in milwaukee last weekend for shows
and you know i was i was
i mean every conversation you're like
the son of a [ __ ] took western pictures
no no you're going like you're going
like this is so i'm so extra thankful to
be able to have so let me ask you this
we talk about
how you felt about
the way he was with your mom
uh western pictures trampolines i know
we joke about them but i know that's a
thing yeah but
during this time where you think you're
gonna lose your dad
are you thinking about
that [ __ ] are you thinking about the
three to four years are you thinking
like [ __ ] what i would give because
for me my dad died when i was 16 and
like the times i would have had before
would have been i'd have been 12
whatever but now
like when he used to be okay i'm gonna
run up to kmart you want to take a ride
i'm like nah play my video game yeah now
of course you don't you don't think of
that so
there's three to four years where you
consciously pushed him out do you think
of that now or during that time i mean
i do
but
i thought more of that stuff i felt more
like
you know either a day or two days before
that we'd you know we'd had a
conversation like we would talk on the
phone versus facetime
but we you know had would have
conversations where i just go all right
well i'm going to take off you know and
i was more thinking of that as well as
how i really only saw him at shows when
he when i would be near where they lived
i'd see him at shows we'd have dinner
you know but it wasn't really like there
wasn't a lot of actual quality time and
i think that is partially because
i was just working a lot and but you
know how it is you could always if you
wanted to make time to take a weekend
you could do that i just wasn't in the
zone of doing that it was more that
stuff i was going you know i really
i should have valued the more recent
moments that that time
i don't want to say anything justifies
that but
even if we talk about it now he and i
i feel like i can explain why i made
that decision you've never actually had
that conversation like openly about that
not maybe about that specifically about
the reasons why the rationale behind it
you know and he owns like a lot of that
stuff um
you know as does my mother i mean they
they own their their portions of it but
but yeah he
i think and again he's also so forgiving
which obviously trickled down to me
but he is he's he's so like
understanding that i think he made me
never feel guilt about it so maybe in a
way he kind of freed me from that but i
i was thinking more of those things the
time when i should have just taken a day
and just hung out with him when i was in
milwaukee or madison or whatever
um
but yeah and that was you know that was
like
five six months ago so it's like oh damn
yeah so it's just crazy it was a crazy
all right
now that we've talked about all this
it's your first time on here and i
always ask people advice to give their
16 year old self so
especially this is right in that
wheelchair
right what advice would you have for
your 16 year old self well i mean
particular like i would say
you know
embrace the nightmare it'll make the
dream easier
because i really was like that's it
man that's [ __ ] well said well i
never really shocked that you said
something like that someone wrote it for
me
[Laughter]
you know even when you're in traumatic
times now it's very hard to see
out of it but when it's like your first
super dark traumatic time
or even just being a teenager i mean i
remember telling my little brothers and
sisters from the western pictures
and the trampoline that you know like
when they would be the love and the love
and all the you know the list they got a
lot of credits honestly
okay enough we're good jesus pump the
brakes for a second i don't need help
um but i remember explaining to them at
one point being like look you're 15 like
your life's supposed to feel [ __ ]
weird right now and too much and you
know
i never felt i never had anyone really
say that to me like you're you're going
through just this really [ __ ] weird
time um
i would have told my you know that it's
when you're young years feel so much
more precious than when you're old when
you've had so many so you're so locked
into that moment there
you can't see out of it and yet when you
do get out of it it's that sort of stuff
that kind of helps not only form you but
helps form your ability
to take on things and respond to things
and
um and handle life and it's it's a
lesson that you can only be taught if
some [ __ ] happens like your father
dying or yeah you know i'm not the same
person today if that doesn't happen no
and and in a way though like it's it's
different for your situation but
it it's as much as you you always want
the situation to be right and you would
much rather your like it formed you you
you have formed into who you are you've
got you know like you said the response
the way you're going to take care of
your daughter more like
it it helped it helps you whether it's
yeah absolutely and i and i always look
back and go you know
i'm glad it happened to me it was so bad
the the parent stuff but it like you
know i do feel the same way yeah so so
that's what i'd say that's [ __ ] great
dude um well thank you for coming on
here thank you
such a good episode dude you kill me
yeah everything we're [ __ ] so far
you're so fast and so funny
um
please plug promote everything again uh
yeah so go to garethreynolds.com i'm on
tour currently i'm going to the east
coast uh soon and then i don't know
where i'll be when this comes out but go
to airthrones.com go to
dolloppodcast.com we have a bunch of
shows coming up and then go to gareth
reynolds tv on youtube and subscribe and
then uh at reynoldsgareth on social
media because a welsh guy took gareth
reynolds all right man uh thank you
again thank you thank you dude a
pleasure and as always ryan sickler on
all social media ryan sickler.com we'll
talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you